he is Richard standing me here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Richard good
how are you rich I'm doing fine what
what did you learn about prior to the
Yankees that you four sports fans about
this movie that you may not have already
known well there's a whole lot of stuff
and I'll start with one scene that was
cut out it was it was in the script it
might have been filmed but I don't know
for sure but in the very beginning in
the film where young Lou is playing in
the Sandlot with his friends there's a
scene that was written that had Lou
facing the kid pitching him and all of a
sudden the kid becomes Christie
Mathewson and the little Sandlot becomes
the Polo Grounds and Lou is still
twelve-year-old Lou and he hits a home
run to win a World Series game and he's
carried on on the shoulders of his of
his teammates and he he's given like the
key to the city and it's the very
dramatic scene and it was probably a
little too expensive to shoot so it was
cut out but I I learned you know Eleanor
Garrick had a very very strong role from
the very beginning when she signed her
deal with Samuel Goldwyn to make the
film she huddled for several weeks with
Paul Gallico who in later years would
become famous for writing the Poseidon
Adventure but he was the first writer on
the film into the outline he did the
script the first script and he she sort
of spilled out her life with Lou in ways
that she didn't in her own book about
him in ways that I've never seen before
there's 38 pages of notes that Gallico
kept and in letters that she wrote to
Goldwyn and says Christie Walter agent
you saw how focused she was on looking
at the script and vetting it for factual
errors so she says at one point to
Goldwyn you can't have Miller Huggins in
a suit
signing Lou to his contract she lost
that battle because that's what we did
see so Eleanor didn't win all her battle
she really wanted is you she had a
version of the other Gehrig speech that
she wanted the movie to follow slavishly
she lost that battle completely perhaps
in part because she started off as she's
not debating this well after the movie
was
production but Eleanor's role was very
important looking at the evolution of
the various roles mother Gehrig who is a
difficult character especially in her
relationship with Eleanor in the movie
was painted as so did like this is
really nasty just off the boat German
immigrant and the script had her
speaking the the script is written in
sort of like phonetic English so it's
you'd see all these German German isms
that she was supposed to be saying so
she she evolved throughout the film
Lew and Eleanor pretty much stayed the
same but they're there there's so much
that changed a little kid that that
LeWitt's to four months for the world
series that role changed numerous times
he was a poor kid he was a rich kid and
the the scene towards the end before Lou
makes a speech for Gary Cooper makes a
speech where the kid now a teenager has
recovered and is no longer has polio
that was written at the last minute that
wasn't even in the script well I mean
for those who may not have seen this
movie and for whom you know Gehrig is a
familiar name but everybody else that
you just mentioned is unfamiliar
why would somebody how does it stand up
today seeing this movie with Gary Cooper
playing very very well and I think part
of it is the instinct that Samuel
Goldwyn had Goldwyn knew nothing about
baseball Gary Cooper had never played
baseball the cinematographer had never
played never seen baseball so but
Goldman's instinct was this baseball was
toxic it was box-office poison he didn't
want to make a baseball film and he had
to be persuaded to make this he wanted
this to be a romantic film the story of
a courageous man who who is you know
dies you know you know has a fatal
illness so what holds up about it is
number one the speech and number two the
relationship that Gary Cooper and Teresa
Wright have in the film it's a very
chaste romance but you can see through
the teasing and the sweetness and and
how much they truly adored each other
that that that holds up people still cry
when they when they
see her kind of goofing around towards
the end when he's going out to me is
he's leaving the house to make the
speech she's doing her best she's crying
as she sees Cooper struggle to make a
bowtie and to button is the the buttons
of his shirt it's a very emotional film
and you could say that the baseball
action isn't great and it's not there's
very little of in actuality but it
doesn't matter and think of 1942 when it
came out people weren't criticizing the
baseball action as they would now now
you can't have an a guy who'd never
played baseball starring in a role like
this when chadwick boseman played Jackie
Robinson 242 or Kevin Costner in
baseball films he was in you knew these
were athletic guys and maybe they needed
some tips from some special consultants
who worked on the film but they had they
didn't have that kind of apparatus left
do dual helped Lou Gehrig learned how to
play baseball he learned for baseball in
six weeks and yes it's not that great at
it
but you never actually see him connect
back to ball so in six weeks
he developed a swing that was
implausible it wasn't bad the far away
shots were not in they would Babe Herman
the former Brooklyn Dodgers star and you
know but getting back to what white
holds up it's because it's it's a human
relationship it's not just it's where
baseball film nobody remember it if not
for Gary Cooper I don't think it would
be remembered at all and as I point out
Goldwyn went on a Scarlett O'Hara light
casting casting tour to try to find
somebody to play Gehrig even though he
I'm sure he knew that Cooper was going
to do it think of Eddie Albert as Lou
Gehrig well I mean I'd get that bet that
I don't for those who definitely
remember Eddie Albert definitely no that
wouldn't have worked out I'm with
Richard Sandom your author of the pride
of the Yankees Lou Gehrig Gary Cooper in
the making of a classic I'd be remiss if
I didn't ask you from your old days of
what you did with the New York Times
what do you think of Romo joining the
booth for CBS do you think he's got the
chops to do something like that Richard
you know
it's always it's a crapshoot on guys
like that because he's judged to be
someone who answered questions
thoughtfully it's a leap to whether they
can action whether he can actually be
proactive and deliver analyses I
honestly don't know I I've never hit the
times I've seen him answer questions he
didn't seem to be any more than maybe
above-average so but we have to think
back how was Phil Simms in that role how
was a Qin in that role when they were
still players they had to be chosen
based on that and based on their
performances and production meetings
that networks have with teams before the
weekend before the games so you don't
know it's it's a very tough choice to
make I think it was very abrupt to say
okay Phil Simms you can't do this
anymore
or we'd rather have somebody young who's
fresh awfully it was fresh off the field
instead of 20 years past past they're
there they're playing days
I think it's a very tough decision to
make it's it's risky because the his
first season Romo may be no better than
the third or fourth guy in the CBS depth
chart and what I guess I could pretty
much get your answer about Cutler then
but if you're going to be judging by
some media interaction Cutler never
never impressed me as anybody I'd want
to listen to when he was answering
questions seems so and difficult and his
career never measured up the way it
should
Romo may have missed the ultimate but
Romo was a far more successful
quarterback in the Cowboys more
successful in his time then cut the
Westmont with the Broncos or you know or
for the Bears last one for you Richard
about your book prior to the Yankees Lou
Gehrig Gary Cooper in the making of a
classic so Babe Ruth played himself in
this movie any good stories about how he
got involved in this film well you know
he was he lost a lot of weight to play
himself so he got so sick that he was
hospitalized for pneumonia but also
during the filming of the movie you may
there's a scene where the Yankees are
celebrating winning the World Series on
a train
going back to New York and Ruth got so
excited while filming the scene that he
bashed his hand through a plate-glass
window and had to be hospitalized for
breaking blood vessels and so on he he
was just a little too rambunctious and
he made you know one could speculate
that he may have had a little too much
booze between you know on the set or
something like that but the babe to me
babe played himself very well and Elinor
did not want him in the movie at all she
was afraid he was going to steal scenes
that even the movies
her husband's her husband would be in
the shadow of Babe Ruth but I think he
played himself very well and if you
could ask Elinor now where she Glenn he
played himself in the movie I think
she'd say yes because he added to it
basically the third star of the movie
you know you can say Walter Brennan was
the third star
but Babe Ruth was a bigger star to
baseball fans going to see the movie
interval to Brennan was and I think I
think they did a terrific job Congrats
on the book Richard thank you rich
thanks having me out yo you bet at rich
sand amir on twitter author of the pride
of the Yankees Lou Gehrig Gary Cooper in
the making of a classic the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint